antibiotics we use them frequently to
treat bacterial infections and they are
very good at their job however concerns
have been rising about the creation of
superbugs which are fatal bacteria that
are resistant to our arsenal of
antibiotics
what is antibiotic resistance and how do
bacteria become resistant to the
antibiotics we choose to kill them in
this video we will be focusing on a
strain of antibiotics known as amino
glycosides which work by inhibiting the
function of a bacterial cells ribosomes
ribosomes are organelles which make
proteins they work by mashing sections
of mRNA containing the cell's genetic
code with matching sections of tRNA
which carry amino acids creating a
protein the ribosome itself is made up
of RNA and proteins the 30s ribosomal
subunit is a section of our RNA which
ensures that only the strongest codon
anticodon pairs can bond antibiotics
bind to and alter the xxx structure
allowing for weaker and correct parents
to be formed the wrong protein is formed
and the bacterial cell is either stopped
from growing or killed some bacteria
however have developed enzymes known as
methyl transferases which add methyl
groups to specific bases in the our RNA
the addition of a methyl group makes the
pocket where the antibiotic normally
binds to small which allows ribosomal
function to continue as normal
3d models are methylated our RNA can be
found on the PDB website here we see a
section of our RNA where a methyl group
has been added to a blondie here we see
similar structure added to an adenine
other methods of antibiotic resistance
exist as well in one method bacterial
enzymes add chains and molecules to
antibiotics which one activates them
another method bacteria develops pumps
which expel into biotics from within the
cell and yet another method bacterial
cells develop less permeable cell
membranes which stops antibiotics from
entering antibiotic overuse is the
biggest cause of antibiotic resistance
killing weaker bacterial strains allows
mutated strains to spread an antibiotic
resistance epidemic is in our future of
antibiotics keeping rendered ineffective
however it's not too late according to
the World Health Organization you can
help slow antibiotic resistance by only
using antibiotics when prescribed never
sharing antibiotics and regularly
washing your hands to prevent infection
if you want to learn more about
antibiotics and antibiotic resistance
feel free to visit the PDB website
thanks for watching